[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening and welcome to the table
i am so glad to see you guys it has been
a great week because it was my birthday
week and i
way to go
i love my birthday unashamedly i used to
pretend like i didn't but i actually i
really love birthdays and i really love
my birthday so it's been a great week
for me i hope it has for y'all too i'm
so glad you're here and that you chose
to be with us tonight on this sunday
evening
um that is a gift to me i feel like
every week showing up in this space is
like going to
someone's house and sitting down and
everyone's in their seats at the table
and so it's a great name for our church
is the table because it truly is this
metaphorical place that is just sweet
and a great meal before us with the
worship the message
it's going to be good um announcements
we are going to be having a lovely
christmas eve service on
december 24th that's the sunday or the
friday before
the 26th
and on the 26th we will not be having
service the christmas eve service will
be at 4 30. you should invite your mom
your dad your neighbor whoever you want
it's going to be super special and we
would love to have you here
um and then no
service that following sunday so stay
home enjoy your presence enjoy the
lord's presence and just rest
and um
yeah those are our announcements for
this sunday and i'm going to i want to
read to y'all
one of my favorite
excerpts from
this letter that paul wrote
the sun stands first in the line of
humanity god restored we see the
original and intended shape of our lives
there in jesus
after god made the decision of what his
children should be like he followed
followed it up by calling people by name
after he called them by name he set them
on a solid basis with himself and then
after getting them established he stayed
with them to to the end gloriously
completing what he had begun
so what do you think
with god on our side like this how can
we lose
if god didn't hesitate to put everything
on the line for us embracing our
condition and exposing himself to the
worst by sending his own son is there
anything else
he wouldn't gladly and freely do for us
as we enter this time of worship i just
want to
pray together
and get started at this feast at our
table
god thank you for another day that
wasn't promised to us but given to us
thank you for the gift of being in
relationship with you knowing you and
thank you for knowing us by name
for
making a way for us
in spite of us because you love us god
thank you for calling us by name knowing
us by name and giving this gift
freely
as a good father would your
unconditional love
is our hope our joy our light in the
darkness and i pray god for eyes to see
it
hearts to know it and move by the truth
of that and as we enter into this time
of worshiping you i pray that our weeks
before us
are just silenced that are weak behind
us is silenced and we meet here tonight
at this table and feast on your goodness
your grace your love together and we are
bonded together in a way that we are
holding hands tighter
and in worshiping you in that and
holding one another up and i'm
glorifying you god we we love you we
need you we praise you amen
would you stand with us
this week um our sister mindy who you
normally see is on an anniversary trip
with josh her husband and um they're in
mexico living it up and
so we are here with you in cold texas
but it's warm in here and it's warm to
be together
so let's just yeah
go and go along with what kelly said and
be in this place together
thanks for having me
[Music]
tell it on the mountains
that jesus christ is
help us born this together
while shepherds kept their watching
or silent flocks by night
behold throughout the heavens
there's shown a holy light
go
tell it on the mountains
over
tell it on the mountain
that jesus christ is born
[Music]
while shepherds feared and trembled
over the hills
that jesus christ
[Music]
was born
and brought us god's salvation
that blessed christmas
that jesus christ is born
now jesus christ is born
that jesus christ
hey guys we wanted to start off with a
little christmas spirit
but um i feel like those words we've
been watching christmas music movies as
a family
the christmas spirit is like the now the
language in our house christmas spirit
but um we're gonna actually transition
right now into a practice that we like
to take part in here it's actually part
of christian tradition down through
hundreds of years but it's called
prayers of the people and it's a time
for us to come together and share our
burdens and carry one another's burdens
by praying for one another
so
what we're gonna do is there's gonna be
a call and response where the words of
the prayer on the screen and i'm gonna
lead us out in that but the parts that
are in red if you guys would say that
together with us as a community so that
we can just stand together in this and
then um i'll leave some open space for
people to just speak out
um names and situations that are on your
heart without you know sharing anyone's
private information and being respectful
of that we do want to carry those things
to god together and i believe brett will
be reading off
any online comments so for those of you
who are joining us online tonight
please also
feel welcome to participate in this time
and if you'll type out um in the comment
section below your request we'll be sure
to read those out as well um so that you
can be part of this time with us
so
um let me pull up
our prayer here and if you guys will
join with me in this
for this city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
and the wisdom and will to conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old
and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
from online nancy's chemo treatments
teachers and educators and students
[Music]
the parker family
sarah
and kirsten
[Music]
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud
and for those we have kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
i wanna know you lord
like i know a friend
[Music]
so i'm laying down
all my religion
i'm laying down
i wanna know you lord
all my religion
i'm laying down
i wanna know
i used to think
that i could box you in
but i'm laying down
i want to know you
lord
i used to think
that i could box you in
[Music]
wanna know
lord i've been told
to be ashamed
i don't measure
up
lord i've been told
i'm not good enough
but you're here with me
yeah we're gonna hang right there for a
minute
and i wanted to just take a moment
and look inside those areas where you
maybe are hiding
those areas where maybe you feel need to
stay hidden
areas that maybe you feel ashamed or
maybe someone has made you feel ashamed
of
and i want you to hear this next part
as your hope
that god
that he sees you
he doesn't run
from those areas that are tender and
hurting
he doesn't run he comes close and he's
there
and he's with you
and that he continues to go with you
to heal the ashamed and hiss or the
shame
to heal the brokenness
god sees brokenness as beauty not his
weakness
and that he wants to give you this hope
and i hope that this yeah that's gives
you hope
[Music]
lord i've been told
to be ashamed
lord i've been
told i don't measure
up
lord i've been told
i'm not good enough
but you're here with me
[Music]
i reach out and you
you find
[Music]
and me say no amount of untruth
can separate
us i reach out i reach out
i reach out and you
you find me
in the dust
and this ain't no amount of untruth
[Music]
sing that one more time i reach out
i'll reach out and you
find me in the dust
[Music]
and you say no amount of untruth
can separate
i will rejoice
in the simple gospel
[Music]
i will rejoice
in the sinful gospel
i will
[Applause]
[Music]
i rejoice
rejoice in a simple gospel
i will rejoice
in you
lord
i will rejoice
in the simple gospel
[Music]
we rejoice in your freedom
we rejoice
[Music]
i could just sit
i could just
i hope to feel your presence
i could just stay
i could just stay right where i am and
hope to feel you
hope to feel something again
[Music]
i could hold on
i could hold on to who i am and never
let you
change me from the inside
i could be safe
i could be safe here in your arms and
never leave home
never let these walls down but you will
call me
you have called me higher
you have called me deeper
and i'll go where you will lead me lord
you'll lead me
lord
[Music]
i will be yours
i will be yours for all my life
i will be yours oh
[Music]
i will be yours for all my life so let
your mercy
i will be
yourself i will be yours for all my life
so let your mercy
light the pathway for me cause you have
called me higher
you have hold me deeper and i'll go
where you will lead me low
you have called me higher
you have called me deeper and i'll go
where you will lead me
lord
you will call me higher
you have caught me deeper and i'll go
where you will lead me
lord
[Music]
me
yes jesus
we thank you that we can trust you with
our hearts
our hearts of brokenness
our hearts of joy
we thank you that we can trust you with
every
every part of us god
and lord we thank you that you do lead
us that you walk with us as a friend as
a guide god
thank you that
yeah that you offer our hand every
every single day you offer to walk with
us step by step
and god i just pray that
tonight that you would
fill us with hope
hope for each day to come
and lord i just pray
that you would open up our hearts open
up our ears
to hear lord the message that brett has
that you put on his heart
and i pray that you would lead and guide
him
in jesus name amen
[Music]
you guys turn to somebody and say hello
and say glad you're here you look so
beautiful
well good evening
everybody
grace and peace
my name is brett
most of you know that
perhaps if you don't which is why i say
it every week and so i'm the founding
faster here and it's really really
wonderful um to be with you guys and i
hope um
i hope you're wrapping up your christmas
shopping like you're getting close
anyone not started
that you that would one of it know okay
maybe y'all are on it y'all are that's
pretty good or maybe you just don't want
to admit it that's okay i'm um
i'm not sure if i'm done yet
check
on my my christmas you want me
we tried
all right
back to this one our ongoing mics
almost every week
all right there we go
um
all right so okay so i was saying um
yeah i'm not sure if i'm done yet i need
to check with max because maggie will
tell me if like at the list we haven't
really gotten buttoned up yet you know
so gotta we'll see we'll see how
um
uh
it's possible
okay i'm not done until i buyers
so um
all right all right before i get in more
trouble i'm gonna keep moving so we are
in uh let's see this is part three in
our series um wonder making room for
advent and um
as we talked about a few weeks now uh
there's a difference between advent and
christmas advent is basically
preparation
for christmas so it's you can kind of
think of it as like a season of um like
intense prayer if you've ever been a
moment where you really need god to come
through and so
you're just like longing and hoping and
praying
for god to show up in a big way and
that's basically what advent is it's
really that hard posture um of uh of
really longing for god to show up uh
which is right that's different than the
moment of fulfillment or where god shows
up and it's great and it's like yes this
is what i needed that's you know
christmas that's like the moment of
incarnation and god among us um so
advent's kind of the you know the
looking ahead looking forward um
so with that in mind the the title of my
message tonight is uh do something
do something and um our primary text is
actually going to follow right on the
heels of where we were last week so if
for those of you who were here last week
we were in luke chapter 3 verses 2
through 6. it was the whole um john the
baptist or john the baptizer maybe less
confusing and uh it was his story of you
know he's out in the wilderness um and
there he received a word from god uh and
so this kind of is just literally right
after that so that was that ended in
verse six and so this week we're like
right into verse seven uh verses seven
through eighteen so
john receives this message and then he
goes out and uh he starts preaching it
so um here's kind of this is his uh one
of his kind of basic messages so verse 7
it's very intense by the way so buckle
up
john said to the crowds coming out to be
baptized by him
you brood of vipers
what a charmer
who warned you to flee from the coming
wrath produce fruit in keeping with
repentance and do not begin to say to
yourselves we have abraham as our father
for i tell you that out of these stones
god can raise up children for abraham
this was a big deal for that culture
right it was the idea of um
really uh identity like were the people
of god were the children of abraham the
other you know nations they're not
and so there was kind of a certain um
kind of nationalistic status that was
like we are the children of abraham and
and kind of um
buying into that like it even became not
so much about how you lived but just you
know you're just born into it
you know and so he's saying like
be careful
like god can raise up children of
abraham out of the stones around you
um
verse nine the ax is already at the root
of the trees and every tree that does
not produce good fruit will be cut down
and thrown into the fire
verse 10. what should we do then the
crowd asked john answered anyone who has
two shirts should share with the one who
has none anyone who has food should do
the same
even tax collectors can be baptized
teacher they asked what should we do
don't collect any more than you're
required to he told them and some
soldiers asked him and what should we do
he replied don't extort money don't
accuse people falsely be content with
your pay
the people were waiting expectantly they
were all wondering in their hearts if
john might possibly be the messiah
john answered them all i baptize you
with water but one who is more powerful
than i will come the straps of whose
sandals i am not worthy to untie he will
baptize you with the holy spirit and
fire his winnowing fork is in his hand
to clear his threshing floor to gather
the wheat into his barn but he will burn
up the chaff with unquenchable fire and
with many other words john exhorted the
people and proclaimed the good news to
them
isn't that a great little ending i love
that it's this i mean it's so intense
right and then with many other words he
sorted the people encouraging them uh
calling them to the good news you know
it's just it's such a funny ending but
um i actually this isn't um i want to
give a kind of a caveat before i jump
into my message so i know that is a lot
of sort of i mean it's a lot of
metaphors that are all kind of pointing
towards you know like is that like the
hellfire and damnation kind of stuff in
the bible um and if you've been here you
know i've touched on this like a number
of times um so without completely
derailing my message with a 20-minute
caveat i'll just kind of sum it up by
saying
that
this kind of language
i think actually is good news because i
don't think it's about
god saying i am literally going to set
you on fire for eternity
um i think instead when i when i hear
all the language in the bible um about
you know health fires and things like
that i the way i'm interpreting that is
very much in line with where i think
paul went with it and the church fathers
and mothers in the early 10th church it
was always the purifying fires of god's
love
right this is why it's actually good
news even though it strikes us as
somewhat ironic of like oh my gosh that
sounds terrible but it's actually good
news when these things are burned away
from us
right um so anyway if you need like more
on that boy i can point you can just
reach out and i'll send you some some
messages and things where i go more into
that um
but instead where i wanted to go tonight
is really more focused on verse 10. so
it's very interesting to me that john he
brings this absolutely massive critique
basically of the people
um and did you catch their response
right in verse 10
they say what should we believe then the
crowd asked
is that what it says
no
close what does it say what should we
do
then and that interesting like i think
in the modern kind of times maybe the
last few hundred years the church we've
been maybe a little more than slightly
obsessed with belief
you know believe which would mean when
someone kind of brings a critique like
that i think a natural reaction for us
might be something like well okay well
what should we believe then
um what what what creed should we sign
off on what doctrinal statement
would you like me to accept so that i
can i don't know get my heart right
because i don't want that the whole axe
to the roots of the tree thing i don't
want that you know so so what should i
believe i think that's kind of a natural
um
leaning for us but it's interesting it
doesn't like they don't go there and
said they very wisely ask um what should
we do then
and and here's the truth i think
orthodoxy
um which means right belief i think
matters
but
um
really what this passage is getting at
what john and his whole early ministry
emphasized if you read the actual words
of jesus what he placed a tremendous
emphasis on and really the whole season
of advent like the whole heartbeat of
this season of advent what it's really
about is much more about orthopraxy
where the proxy is right action
right so you have orthodoxy right belief
orthopraxy right action
and that's that's the emphasis of this
text
and um
and really what that's getting at is
it's less about believing all the right
things
and it's more getting at um
do the right things live the right
things
so there was a writer james k smith he's
a
christian philosopher and i talked about
him quite a bit in our deconstruction
series for those of you who were here i
quoted him a few times he's i found him
very helpful any book by james k smith i
uh i recommend it
but um but he's really helped me with
the idea of understanding the
relationship of orthodoxy and
orthopraxy
so i think the way we tend to think of
this relationship is probably that
orthodoxy comes first right so it's um
let me believe the right things
and then once i get all my beliefs like
worked out
then what
then then i'll live right y'all like we
don't know when it's rhetorical brett so
you can't just spring it on us like that
um
right then i'll live then i'll do it
right and and i think this becomes a
huge um this is where we get the
emphasis right because it's like we yeah
we want to get our beliefs all
straightened out um
but actually i think so maybe the
paradigm
is we often think of it in terms of
thinking
feeling
doing
right this is i would say kind of our
default in the west like let me think
once i get my beliefs right then i'll
feel a certain way then i'll feel like
doing the right thing
right but what if it's actually reversed
what if it's actually
doing
feeling
thinking
um this is what james k smith contends
and actually if you look into like
modern neuroscience and stuff that's
really where it's starting to point um
you can think of it
like
a metaphor that some i think
neuroscientists have given is sort of
like a rider on a wild elephant
not a tamed elephant but a
wild elephant and if the if the writer
is the conscious kind of thinking mind
you know like i'm gonna reason this
through i'm gonna logically think it all
through
but if you think of the wild elephant as
um emotion
and feeling and we've talked a lot about
i mean last
few months desire
you know so if the wild elephant is like
the feeling part of us kind of our gut
you know
like just like it's just what i i know i
just intuit it like i just feel like
this is what's right this is the thing
you know and this is often this is what
the bible calls the heart right and
actually we don't so much live from up
here
right the thinking part of us we live
from our gut we live from our heart we
live from our desires
right that just take us places and then
what neuroscientists would say then we
rationalize it later
and we say well the reason i did that
was because you know i've got arguments
i've got logic i've got right reason
and it's true we have reasons sometimes
but if you like scratch the surface of
those what's really going on it's like
the wild elephant
of our emotions and feelings and desire
like that's like running the show so the
question becomes well how do you steer
the wild elephant how do you guide a
wild elephant like what can what can we
do it's actions
it's it's habits
and
practices
what we might call the the liturgies of
our lives these sort of repetitive
things that we do over and over and over
and over those powerfully shape our
loves and our longings and our desires
and i think this is um
this is why i think this matters for our
advent season
is because we've been now like on you
know weeks on the topic of
you know what can we do to prepare for
the time of our visitation
what what can we do to to get our hearts
right maybe it hasn't been quite as
intense as john but in essence that's
kind of the heart you know you know like
prepare the way
get ready like god in flesh is showing
up among us and he's doing a new thing
in our hearts and minds so let's not
miss the time of our visitation let's be
engaged let's not um run from the
wilderness that was last week of course
right running from seasons of wilderness
like no like no let's embrace it let's
go for it and so the question comes to
us
well how
like how do i do that how on earth would
i get ready for such a thing
and i think where our minds naturally go
is
believe
i know what i need to do i need to
believe it almost becomes a white
knuckle thing i just need to believe
more i need to believe i need to believe
in god i need to believe in christ i
need to i need to get all my beliefs in
order
then i won't miss time my visitation
then i won't run from seasons of
wilderness i mean then i'll get my life
together because i look around all these
people they seem to have their life
together but so they must all believe
but
i'm struggling over here so it must be a
problem of belief can you kind of track
with where i'm going right like this is
what we do
so what i'm naming is that we have it
backwards
that that it's
less about forcing ourselves to believe
and what we should be
zeroing in on
is doing
doing something different not just
thinking something
doing something different why because
that shapes and guides the elephant
what we do how we live
i mean honestly this changes a lot this
changes how
um what are the implications that's like
a church leader it changes how we think
about church and what we do and what it
would even mean to disciple
people into the ways of jesus
because a 10-week course titled doctrine
could be useful i'm not trying to just
be clear i'm not trying to say orthodoxy
doesn't matter if you've been at the
table for a length of time you know like
we care about beliefs thinking maybe
sometimes a little too much i can get a
little too intellectual and lose people
you know so i don't think this is not an
anti-intellectual you know kind of place
um
but it but we've got to keep in mind
that just ideas
like won't get us where we need to go
why because of the wild elephant
right because we live from our gut and
our emotions and our feelings and it
just runs our lives
sometimes
ruins our lives
because that's the place we're living
from
and then the
writers on top
doing their best to kind of guide but
really
the beliefs are sort of along for the
ride
right
so it's it's about our living
um
it's orthopraxy our rituals our daily
routines the liturgies of our lives
these are the things shaping and guiding
the wild elephant may if you've been a
little bit lost on this let me sum it up
with a far better writer than me this is
richard rohr
he says we don't think ourselves into a
new way of living
we live ourselves into a new way of
thinking
that's it
he did it in a sentence i did in 10
minutes it's okay we're getting there
right we don't think ourselves into the
new way we we live ourselves into the
new way of thinking
which is why
the people i think very wisely ask john
in verse 10 not what should we believe
but what should
we do
then the crowd
asked and it's fascinating his response
isn't it we'll go through it in just a
minute for those who've you've forgotten
but it's fascinating because it's
interesting what he says to do it's not
even necessarily the normal spiritual
practices we would probably kind of be
our go-to's and even as a pastor that i
would tend to kind of preach on or be
like what should you do well be here
every sunday you know like this kind of
or read your bible every day or say your
prayers you know although
i think those are powerful spiritual
practices things we do
that do shape
um us and guide us
but that's not all where he goes is it
like instead i mean honestly it's almost
embarrassingly practical
where john
goes i mean it's almost
unspiritual sounding
right
so here it is verse sin what should we
do then the crowd asked
john answered well anyone who has two
shirts
should share
with one who has none
anyone who has food
well they should do the same
is that not fascinating like so here we
are we're asking the big questions
you know like my life's terrible like
god save me what can i do
how can i live in ways that honor you
like how can i not miss the time of my
visitation
how can i not run from seasons of
wilderness like how can i follow your
will and and rebuild this life by your
spirit that you can do amazing things
and
john's like well you could start by
sharing
like sh sharing
is this kindergarten
but the truth is sometimes the simplest
things the most elementary things are
the hardest aren't they
i think this is what's so brilliant
about his response is that he goes right
for our
hearts
honestly he goes right for our hearts
through our
our what they used to call pocket books
i don't think they call it that anymore
through our debit cards
and our credit card like that's did you
notice almost every single one of his
responses is about money
right like what what is going on
he goes right to our heart right to our
possessions and our desires
right to what we do
how we relate to people how we relate to
our possessions and the things we own
it's like it's not quote unquote what we
think of as spiritual even though
apparently what the bible thinks is
spiritual is different than what we
think is spiritual
he goes right for it
and um
[Music]
you know it's interesting if you think
of
john's original listeners
because we maybe take this as like a
metaphor you know shirts metaphorical
but for his original listeners it wasn't
like a metaphor you know so imagine
you live in the first century and you're
so poor
you only have
two
shirts
you got your main shirt and then your
back up shirt
all right when you're washing this one
you wear that one and the next day you
go back to like your fave you know
but you got your new shirt and then your
old shirt that's the only one
and then you're like well how do i get
my life right how do i follow god and
john's like well
don't you have two
two shirts you're like yeah but only two
i only have two john he's like well
you could give that second one
away or imagine you have some food but
not like a lot of food
just a little extra like in the pantry
and john's like well
how about you give that away
like uh
oh gosh this is now what's going on this
is now about kind of trust and faith and
like security and like oh gosh i'm
getting uncomfortable with this
call that john that john has right are
you like are you with me and just to be
clear like i get it i was just recently
um
was it two weeks ago it had been a while
since i've tried to
put some money for our kids like college
you know away at times and um starting
the church and things like that you know
it's been at times lean and whatever you
know starting a new thing that's how it
goes but i just decided to check in like
see how it's going and i need to see
like even where are education costs and
all that you know going and so i'm
looking at things i'm just like oh dear
lord like even just seven years ago when
we started trying to you know do this i
hadn't looked in a while and like
education costs are going crazy and i
was like wait i need wait how much i get
to live off campus or like you really
need like a hundred thousand dollars per
child i'm like
i almost just vomited on my laptop you
know just like oh well that's not
happening
um
so all that to say like i get it you
know i mean housing costs expensive
education costs rising you got the
credit card is like i don't know you
know just trying to make the minimum
payments right like i get life in the
modern world expensive
um and yet i think passages like this do
sort of
shake us out of our first world slumber
a bit
and
um
kind of force us to face the fact that
at least compared to
most of the world even today not just
the ancient world but most of the world
today like we're rich
we are
we are like we are
we're we're all of us
even the poorest among us compared to a
lot of the world like we're rich
you know i mean how many shirts do you
got
do you have 200 shirts
[Laughter]
and yet this is exactly where
john
goes
you know it's it's interesting sometimes
we think you know well like
once i
make more then i'll like you know be
more generous to others but there's been
studies done in the united states and
actually
the um higher our income goes
the less as a total percentage of our
income do we give
you know in other words maybe you're
coming out of college you're like yes i
made 20 grand this year you know and
maybe you gave i don't know like five
percent of your income away or two
percent or something and then whatever
it is
late and you think later once i'm making
like a hundred grand well then i'll be
generous you know but actually what the
statistics would say is that if you gave
five percent when you're making a
hundred grand like you'll technically
give more right it's total dollars but
in terms of percentage
it'll drop down like four percent
and you make two hundred grand three
percent
and that isn't that interesting
like what's going on here um i think uh
maybe a way to write to jot this down if
you want to remember it is um the more i
have the harder it is to part with it
why because that wild elephant
because so much of my hopes and my
dreams and my longings and my desires
they're like all wrapped up
in
what i own and possess
and my securities in that extra food i
got in the pantry and the this you know
the savings account like that's just
where my heart is isn't uh it's
interesting isn't this what jesus
said remember jesus quote for where your
treasure is
there your what your beliefs your brain
will be nope for where your treasure is
there your heart will be also
in other words the core of who you are
will reside
with whatever or whoever you love
the most
that will be the thing
all right that will guide and shape your
life
and i would probably add to that that
that whoever or whatever you love is
actually guided by what you
do
right that's what shaping
that's what's forming
you
and me
and so
this is why i think john says right he
gets very very practical well actually
let's continue this is verse 12.
even tax collectors can be baptized
teacher they asked what should we do
don't collect any more than you're
required to he told him verse 14 then
some soldiers asked him and what should
we do he replied don't extort money
don't accuse people falsely be content
with your pay can you see the theme like
he just keeps on this theme in other
words i think this is why john says
instead of greed
um
give
instead of hoarding
do generosity
instead of lies
and he's the language of extorting
people manipulating people
do the truth live the truth speak the
truth
instead
of
an insatiable desire for more more more
what's his language contentment
be content i mean talk about an
un-american idea contentment
like what do you want in life what do
you desire you know i'm just so happy
with who i am now
you're like
what you loser you know like the do you
want more money nah
i'm good
said no american ever
right and yet this is where he goes
contentment
a few months ago i want to close with a
few stories a few months ago
a friend of mine
graham branson
many of you know graham
and he
he talked to me he came up to me he said
um so hey i noticed
that the table we haven't like done as
many
you know sort of like community
engagement type of events as we used to
and he said like what's up
and i said well yeah that's that's
insightful of you we um
our event coordinator
uh stepped down in like late spring
early summer
and so we honestly just haven't had
someone like spearhead it and take it on
um
and so he said well
i can do that
and this of course is a pastor is a
response i love
because it's easy to say like hey we
should do more of that you should figure
that out brett
but it's really wonderful when someone
says i'll take that on i'll do that and
so you've probably noticed in just the
last few weeks we've had just a handful
of things going on we had the angel tree
drive going for families in need to give
christmas presents
um we had a five loaves food pantry
volunteer day
and a number of you were able to go on
that saturday and go and just prep
clothes and of course it's their holiday
seasons this is a big time of giving and
so we organized clothes and canned goods
and you know did all the things and both
of those were um
i think beautiful things and it's a huge
thanks to graham for organizing that we
also had um nancy purdy
who came up and said this was like three
weeks ago just said hey i heard of a
refugee family
um
she's she's as a mother she's having a
baby shower
and anything we could do to like give
diapers and so we made the announcement
on sunday i know just kind of spur the
moment a number of you like gave diapers
and said oh let me i don't know cash app
you something you know and um like just
contributing
and um
why am i naming all these things because
i think these are beautiful examples of
like
doing
something
because at the end of the day if all of
our orthodoxy
isn't deeply tied to orthopraxy
like our living
then
it's a fair question ask god what the
heck are we doing
right
there's a uh
uh james chapter two i love this story
from james chapter two
i'll kind of tell but i'll kind of
elaborate and paraphrase on it
james this is the brother of jesus
and he says
imagine
that you're at dinner
with your family it's winter time it's
cold outside
and you're just sitting down to family
meal you've got the fire going you know
and right then you hear a knock at the
door
and
it's dark outside you can't see out you
crack the door
and the person they're pretty clearly in
need
you know looks like they've been living
outside for a while it's the
clothes they're shivering in the cold
you ask them like is there something i
can do for you and they say honestly i'm
so sorry i don't mean to intrude but it
is freezing cold out here could you
like spare a sweater
maybe a bite to eat i'm so sorry i don't
mean to inconvenience you i'm just
i'm just really in need here
and
right then this just wave of compassion
just kind of rises up in you
and
as if prompted by the spirit like you
you look at them and you say oh my
goodness
may the lord bless you
and keep you
may he make his face to shine upon you
may his countenance
rise up before you
may he give you grace may he give you
peace may he give you love enjoy
be
warm
be well fed
god bless you
and you close the door
and james says his exact quote is
what good is that that's his quote in
james chapter two
what good is that he says that kind of
so-called
faith
faith is it faith without works without
action orthodoxy without orthopraxy
it is
nothing
it's just
words
just ideas floating in the wind
but to actually
meet a need
to love
to listen to serve to give
but that's divine
that's divine i heard um i think it was
peter rollins
um the philosopher he said
to believe is human lots of humans
believe we're like we believe all sorts
of things to believe is human to love
divine
and so church this advent
like let's
do
let's do something
let's let's love let's serve
let's engage
let's listen
let's reconcile and heal and forgive and
restore
[Music]
like let's
do something not just believe something
let's not just say like we're the people
of god
like let's be
the people of god
and so you might have noticed as you
came in
for our local people
there's little qr codes
and um
those are a link to five loaves food
pantry
in saxey
this is the place we
volunteered like i mentioned uh just a
few weeks ago this is uh an organization
that the table we support
um each month
and um support them financially and they
are they're just doing good work
honestly they're just doing good work in
the world and in our local area just
helping the poor and the needy
and so i want to just encourage you
whether you do it now during this
closing song
or
later
you know let's give it would just be
just be a small moment to like whether
it's five bucks 50 bucks 500 if you got
two shirts
you know
give one
so i encourage i encourage you to uh to
do that
so um let me pray and then we'll have
this closing song and y'all can get on
your phones and
support five loves
lord jesus we
we love you and
um
god we want to not just be people who
claim intellectual beliefs but really
live
lord so fill us with your spirit
i pray every person hearing my voice
whether in person or online that they
would be filled with your spirit and
and it would lead them to love well
it would lead them to serve lead them to
engage
god transform us
tame our wild elephants
god
bring our desires
our feelings into alignment with your
kingdom
do your good work in us
in the name of the father the son and
the holy spirit
amen
well the lyrics of this song are just
one of my favorite prayers ever i just
love the practice like brett said with
that story earlier it's almost
embarrassingly practical
um
but we felt like it just went well with
this message so if you guys
you don't you can be on your phone so we
won't be offended do your thing but
we're going to sing it with us and
we're going to sing it up here and you
can uh
sing along pray along with us as you
feel led
take my life and let it be
consecrated
lord to thee
take my moment in my days
let them flow in
ceaseless praise
take my hands and let them move
[Music]
take my feet and let them be
swift and beautiful
for thee
[Music]
take my voice and let me sing
always only for my king
take my lips and let them be
filled with messages
for
thee
take my silver
and my gold
not a might would i
withhold
take my intention
in youth
every
powers i shall choose
[Music]
take my love my lord i pour
at thy feet it's treasure store
take myself and i will be
ever
only all for thee
ever only all for thee
[Music]
um i started this by saying i'm so glad
that you came to join us for this meal
tonight at our metaphorical church
called the table
and i just love that image i love the
image of us all sitting around a table
and a good meal
that is made for a group this size
online and here in person means that
there are dishes for everyone so i hope
tonight whether it was the the worship
whether it was a prayer whether it was
brett's sermon or someone's smile that
you feasted upon that in a way that you
walk out of here feeling nourished and
you go into this next week just fueled
and ready to love
others
i'm so glad you were here and if this is
your first time visiting as you walk out
there cards we would love truth
genuinely we would love to hear from you
and share some of our story and hear
some of your story
and
i wanted to also mention if the qr code
is not working the website you can go to
is five loaves food pantry dot org
backslash donate
and if that doesn't work just google it
or come and find one of us afterwards um
and then there is a phone number brett's
number that you can text if oh look
there it is that is the website if the
qr is not working
um and then there's a phone number
either out on a card or you can just
come and ask brett for his phone number
or come ask me and i'll totally give it
to you
and um yeah if you want to get more
connected or get to know us more we that
is a genuine invitation
and um
i wanted to share
in honor of like just simplicity i
wanted to share this poem
by um tick net han
and it does kind of feel like a point
that you would maybe read to your
children it's simple in beauty and
there's so much beauty and simplicity in
the way children play and laugh
so um if y'all re uh listen while i read
this you can close your eyes and just
embrace the the simplicity of it
take my hand we will walk
we will only walk
we will enjoy our walk without thinking
of arriving anywhere
walk peacefully walk happily
our walk is a peace walk
our walk is a happiness walk
then we learn that there is no peace
walk
that peace is the walk
that there is no happiness walk that
happiness is the walk
we walk for ourselves we walk for
everyone always hand in hand walk and
touch peace every moment
walk and touch happiness every moment
each step brings a fresh breeze each
step makes a flower bloom under our feet
kiss the earth with your feet
print on earth your love and happiness
earth will be safe
when we feel in us
enough safety
i just loved that i thought that was
beautiful and wanted to share it with
y'all
um and i'm going to close us with the
benediction so if you will rise
and just take a posture of acceptance
you can raise a right hand you can stand
you can close your eyes at the end of
this i'm going to say peace be with you
and you just respond by saying and also
with you and then you are free to go
about your ways
um yeah
so if you'll raise your hands in
acceptance of this
because of jesus alive in you
may you walk and touch peace every
moment
may you walk and touch happiness every
may you kiss the earth that god created
with your feet printing on the earth
your love and happiness
may you go forth hand in hand with a
community who loves you deeply
may the lord's face shine upon you and
you reflect that love on all you
encounter go now in the name of the
father the son and the holy spirit peace
be with you
[Music]
good night my friends